c'est bien ce que tu fais mais il ya des
moments où les gens décrochent c'est
tous les moments les gens et c'est bien
mais décroche mcenroe et décroche ce que
tu sais au moins jeunes hideuse d'asie
dana thonidés sera jamais d'accord mais
tu as l'air tellement content l'asie
donne l'atonie des bombes de ce à quoi
tu t'en fous sur la plage tu démontes
bien ténue bas mais j'ai un rêve quoi
non t'es pas d'accord
ah non c'est vraiment chiant comme ouais
je suis chiante mais je te retrouves
pourquoi tu veux pas me montrer parce
que je veux pas je suis courageux tout
le monde les voit tes saint venant
justement personne je vois mes sens sur
la plage qu'est ce qui va t'arriver toi
j'ai fait un casting de potiche est la
première bonne que je trouve je la
prends je te le dire mais vas-y c'est
dégueulasse mais vas-y fais-le tant qu'à
six mois dégueulasses et la télé ok
allez casse toi c
à thierry oui j'ai bien dit peu inquiet
parce qu'on est à deux minutes du
générique et je n'ai pas vu sandrine
notre petit semble un peu chiche
elle a un contrat avec la télé je
connaisse ah bah c'est dommage qu'on va
le regretter mais j'ai tout essayé
service public tooway leyen
hier c'est bizarre je n'avais pas parlé
de ça lance ici sissi est là mais c'est
qu'elle reste gagner au juste ces japan
mais j'appelle gerry ritz a pas de quoi
cet homme a décidé de prendre tous les
risques
tous les samedis soirs il va relever un
formidable défi vous tenir en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher de
zapper et conserver son hardy matt il
est prêt à tous les moyens sont bons
même la qualité
[Musique]
numéro 5 avec arielle dombasle
dans charly oleg agnès boulard le
professeur rollin et et respect
moyen
le chien
et moi
m
l'eau
au rêve là ou quoi 1 qu'est ce que c'est
que ce public là haut c'est ça que vous
appelez de la joie 1
et ça que vous appelez la bonne humeur
alors on demande un public dynamique et
qu'est ce qu'on fout une ribambelle
d'asthmatiques l'attaché comme des gros
pain on met du four vous êtes chargé de
sauver la salle c'est ça que vous
appelez de la bonne humeur et vous
cherchez l'affrontement mendy ou quoi un
os
bon on ne refait une mais pétillant
cette fois tonique un heureux au
je voudrais remercier le public pour sa
chaleur et sa spontanéité merci
c'est juste
le professeur lantieri vous savez que
traditionnellement je réponds à votre
bon soir par un petit commentaire
pertinent mais là pour ne pas casser le
rythme de l'émission je préfère ne rien
dire du tout ce sera plus rythmé on sera
bleu désigne prophète dans le vif du
sujet c'est sympa merci province à nos
téléspectateurs moyens bonsoir on n'est
pas les mêmes que d'habitude parce qu'il
n'était pas libre et leurs voisins voilà
à malakoff à malakoff
alors ils nous ont demandé et c'est bien
ici ah ça c'est beau on est très cool et
la colère du monsieur là bas qu'est ce
que c'est beau ça se sait on se bat et
mairie cécilia du caractère puissant
bien faire des chips tu vas on est bien
on est venu à where pistes sont sympas
et public et bien ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
sarr est bien avec les téléspectateurs
ça peut aider pour une émission de on
regarde là quand on vous parlait non
regardez votre post je fais les
spectateurs moyens vous regarde moyens
d'abord qui n'a pas ce moyen là très
moyen airelle et jean pierre boutoille
qui vont passer non ben c'est pas ils
sont sur une autre émission ça connaît
un sacré ça serait sympa
ah ouais ça serait sympa enfin bon sens
voilà qui sera pas là on est bien quand
même hein et puis je voudrais dire au
public et lever mon verre
bon alors chanté une chanson que mon
adjudant m'avait dit ça va moi je veux
maintenant à venir ozap un petit peu je
vois maintenant envisageable je sais que
bon nombre d'entre vous sont outrés par
le sort qui lui serait réservé dans le
cas où la part de marché de l'émission
décembre est en dessous de 15%
je tiens à rappeler qu'à l'étranger au
japon et aux etats-unis par exemple la
mise à mort de ce qu'on appelle là bas
des chiens d'audience est une pratique
pour ans il meurt environ dix chiens
d'audience par an aux états unis et la
moitié au japon
sur ces images vous voyez robbie tp
chien d'audience sur une série de nbc
intitulée mari me et qui a été abattu le
soir où la part de marché est descendu
en dessous de 15%
ici vous découvrez aussi qu tient
l'audience sur l'ex grandes émissions de
variétés de la chaîne japonaise nhk
intitulé tun tun a battu lui aussi alors
lorsqu'on accuse de cruauté je réponds
qu'il s'agit d'une pratique courante
dans le monde de la télévision moderne
et que les chiens l'audience sont aux
chiens ce que les taureaux de corrida
sont au taureau puis remettons les
choses à leur place le sort de zap c'est
vous qui décidez en étant suffisamment
nombreux à regarder cette émission
oui il ya thierry comme il est
maintenant de tradition dans cette
émission un petit bilan de la semaine
dernière la séquence qui a réalisé le
meilleur score la semaine dernière c'est
le clip de joe jackson ce qui était
votre idée et l'attiré coup de chapeau
en quatre émissions quatre idées
géniales vous est ce qu'on appelle un
magicien de la télévision
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
je crains que tout magicien que vous
êtes cette fois-ci vous ne puissiez plus
trouver une idée du même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé
germaine jackson le frère de michael
jackson et oui thierry mais comment vous
est venue cette idée géniale j'étais au
restaurant avec ma femme et ma femme un
frère il n'échangeait quoi sans un
discrédit côtelettes d'agneau
professeurs
et j'ai pensé oh vous avez associés est
sûre et du frère andré est frère frère
bouleversant 1 et j'ai pensé à jermaine
jackson
décoiffant mais si jermaine jackson
[Musique]
tous
m
ah ah
[Musique]
oh
pas nous
m
pas
il faut
ceux-là
[Musique]
faux
yu na
[Musique]
ah ah
à
ouais c'est bien c'est bien ouais
m'enfin ça anglais quoi nous on comprend
français à plat en france il a été bon
et moi même si charlie oleg par exemple
ça c'est pour vous dire que ceux
rencontrés sur le plateau de tourner
mais non mais non faut pas dire ça
des nouveaux monstres et voilà que
charlie c'est un peu le paraguay mais
charly oleg en place
ouais si charlie relégué son orgueil
formidable s'enlaçant lorsque charlie
bien mais leurs bombes
voici charly oleg son summer games
[Applaudissements]
je vous disais tout à l'heure
le sexe la violence et la bagnole n'ont
jamais fait
à l'audience il ya plus fort le rire
nous allons donc commencer cette
émission parce qu'il fait aujourd'hui
les plus gros scores d'audience à la
télévision
le comice paraître bizarre mais étirer
le comique pourquoi pas le comique
simplement si vous voulez vraiment faire
décoller l'audimat fait du comique morts
vous savez les chiffres montrent que le
comique mort fait trois fois plus de
points que le comique vivant alors fait
donc donné une bonne petite rafale de
comics mort ça va cartonner comique
morts figurez vous il ya beaucoup de
publicité athée vision surtout pour la
lessive
vous avez vu on doit en manger parce que
nous avons des normes euro 6 je ne sais
pas si on est alors vous avez par an
madame oui je vois vous avez un baril
d'arrière en effet si je vous le reprend
et besoin de deux gardiens décrit habana
et forêts de conques ont pas prendre de
varier de la plaza imagine la bonne
femme il ya d'un merci veux saluer les
paroles mais là c'est pas bon en coupe
et on va la faire venir en aide alors
vous avez vous avez le nouvel os mobile
le nouvel os mobile a encore plus blanc
pascal anciens homo il avait blanc sous
les vivats valait mieux changer
voilà le nouveau dans les lave
encore plus blanc alors le nouveau il a
encore plus blanc parce que blanc - je
sais je sais comme couleur c'est blanc -
blanc que blanc je me doute ça doit être
clair mais plus blanc que blanc et ce
serait comme couleur c'est nouveau ça
vient de sortir
alors alors alors le nouvel os mots
c'est celui qu'il avait la tâche qui est
caché dans le noeud du torchon
on se dit alors si on est aussi content
ça alors regardez c'est en vrai à
l'atterrissage à pompe à une belle femme
qui est un torchon avec une tâche
je sais pas comment ils font la tâche
des jeunes peut-être ils se mettent à
plusieurs il ya des concours ou alors
j'ai pas mon meilleur trajet ou je ne
sais pas qui des animaux je ne sais pas
pas vraiment un tacle sur la fin ça
n'arrive pas à vraiment faux
m'appartiennent éléphant ça ne s'est pas
l'éléphant pauvres n'avaient pas mangé
en fin de journée à bord fera pas non
plus maintenant on tient la sade ça va
être un bon alors écoute moi j'ai même
plus c'est bon je suis là qu'est ce que
j'aime bien et voilà il se chiffre à
arbas la monf où j'ai les noms de ceux
qui font les congeler non bon alors vous
avez à voilà alors le pensions alors à
lui nos tâches et lauriane bonne fin de
carrière dans le siège à telle est la
bonne fin et c'est même pas un nouvel
homo et lee kun-hee voisine
elle arrive à l'infini gros ça je m'en
fous nouvelle au go et l'autisme une
bonne nouvelle ou vos ne voulait même
pas du tout ça alors l'hôtel iberia je
prends mon temps sur il ya un beau stade
je fais un noeud un but en plus du temps
je fais un le jeu mais la machine je
sens la chine jeu des fenouils a plus la
grosse tache et l'hôtel si c'est aussi
propre qu'avec l'ancien homos comme the
pool me c'est plus long faut faire le
plein
celui qu à 5 kg de linge vous faites les
nous l'a dit vous fait la lessive le
mardi puis après tu as la semaine qu'on
ait parlé le lait ne l'ont été dans
l'aube au jour à l'automne
et pourquoi tu tousses alors voilà
pourquoi je t'appelle je suis le petit
café à côté de la douane là et je suis
en face du secrétaire aux touches f
douaniers et où il est le bicarbonate
abbaye risquez rien il est dans les
mains du secrétaire autre chef douaniers
à l'eau tapas et pas du tout ce we elle
relaie pourquoi tu t'appelles trois fois
rien c'est bénin bénin bénin bénin
tu sais les 20 kg de bicarbonate oui
alors lui douaniers les apaiser il
s'avère qu'il ya 20 kg 500 grammes oui
alors il peut payer une petite taxe
qu'on laisse 1 100 g de france en quarts
c'est pas cher alors le reçu est-ce que
je dois le mettre à mon moi ou attendant
c'est pour ça que je t'appelle tu
emportes oui c'est le but
c'est le but de mon téléphone c'est pour
ça que je t'appelle tu entends pas ce
que ton adresse exacte c'est bien 235
cours belsunce à marseille 2e étage
porte gauche non bon ben écoute la taxe
est jamais très abondants
oui et à le douanier qui rigole dit
c'est bien la première fois que je vois
rigoler un douanier d'une façon aussi
intelligent sinon alors une petite
anecdote est trois fois rien tu sais
qu'ils ont analysé le bicarbonate à
l'otan
pourquoi tu tousses ça mais pas du
bicarbonate ces dix et trente secondes l
autocar
pourquoi tu tousses plus il ya besoin de
télé j'ai été saisi d'un bourdon gt que
mason j'ai bien vu
pauvre d'avoir il avait une petite bille
aujourd hui âmes endormies a besoin de
fidéliser une angoisse soupe au lait
malheureux des pays aux gens qui crèvent
de faim est le même chez nous maintenant
avec tous ces nouveaux baux de même des
blocs présente c'est pas du leader
salez restant une petite erreur dans
votre série de comics mort il ya une
petite erreur laquelle fernand raynaud
n'est pas mort ainsi à si si je vous
assure fin de rennes on abat autant pour
moi alors c'est triste c'est un peu
regrettable
il est mort après le rire le sport tout
ça c'est parfait pour l'audience et puis
c'est normal sur france 2 la chaîne du
tour de france de roland garros
d'albertville de barcelone le gérard
holtz de patrick chêne de robert
chapatte de roger couderc de thierry
adam thierry roland et les super toi tu
hesdinois et après tu sais noir c'est
noir oui mais si ces blancs ses plans
c'est noir ou blanc mais ce n'est pas
noir et blanc c'est comme ci comme ça
oui tu veux ou tu veux pas
[Musique]
non en fait
oui c'était
[Musique]
et c'est comme
m
[Applaudissements]
e
ya trouvé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les mois
bhopal tu là
[Applaudissements]
partez végétation
oh la la
[Applaudissements]
oh là là là là ce n'est pas joli joli
thierry vous nous annoncez du sport et
vous nous diffuser des cochonneries
vous êtes un gros malhonnête kerry je
l'avais pas vu ce truc là je viens de
découvrir comme bout j'avais pas vu le
montage c'est vrai ce mensonge juan
professeurs non non c'est vrai
maintenant je vais vraiment pas vu puis
là je vais vous montrer un truc qui va
vous il va vous plaire c'est plus
intello c'est une interview de jacques
derrida
enfin vous allez voir comment vous
pensez aujourd'hui le rapport entre
philosophie littérature et à ce que
finalement les parcours qui ont été les
vôtres et dans la philosophie et dans la
littérature ne vous conduisent pas à
penser que l'écriture littéraire
finalement résout des problèmes que la
philosophie pose sans être capable de
les résoudre
j'essaie de rassembler là c'est tout
simple les et des références
essentielles littéraire qui sont les
vôtres et quand on fait cette
bibliothèque
on se dit c'est vraiment quelque chose
en commun et c'est sur quelque chose en
commun que tu voudrais vous entendre
artaud bataille
joyce blanchot c'est pas le scellant au
fond qu'est ce qui rassemble ces
écrivains qu'est-ce qu'il fait leur
pourquoi sont-ils dans votre panthéon
c'est certainement pas
théo d'abord 7,7 s'est ouvert ensuite
j'hésite à répondre à cette question là
parce que si je répondais je dirais
voilà c'est en ont quelque chose en
commun et ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce
qu'ils ont en commun
très bonne surprise parce que ce
document est très intellectuel et
pourtant le la courbe n'a pas cessé de
monter comme quoi contrairement à une
idée reçue bien la culture ça peut aussi
payer sur le service public c'est
formidable c'est pas fini professeurs
apprennent rire le sport cette veille de
saint valentin
personne ne sera étonné de me voir faire
de l'audience avec les plus belles
histoires d'amour
[Musique]
alors à part ça
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
olé olé olé je suis disposé à diable en
échange de la maison n'ont pas je te
passe à dire la mosaïque à
l'atterrissage je vais t'aider que tu le
veuilles ou non ça marchera pas il va
pas y arriver et a pas la force c'est
trop lourd mon fils est inquiète
on y va
aurait pu marcher bien j'essaie
d'atteindre la rampe hommes balance non
c'est surtout pas savoir pourquoi
j'essaie de l'ombre qui tombe dessus
la bonne celle là
j'avais
que vous attendez que c'est moi paris la
voiture de soin de vous voilà j'ai cru
que vous n'arriveriez jamais qu'ils sont
là ils ont perdu les pédales ou pas mon
lit je crois que si la peine de
s'arrêter l'histoire moi j'avais tout ce
qui s'est passé j'étais toujours aimé et
je suis sûr de thé mais toujours je sais
et toi aussi tu m'as toujours aimé
réponse simple et toujours rien non non
écouter on va entrer oliver barbara
gabut la vie et c'est de trouver une
échelle je savais que ça finirait bien
[Musique]
sa chérie tu vois ses deux fils
électriques chacun d'eux peut supporter
disons une centaine de kilos au moins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
probable j'ai appelé maintenant elle en
a pleuré de bonheur
elle veut que vous portiez sa robe de
mariée en dentelles non je ne peux pas
me marier dans la vente de votre mais je
l ai moi nous ne sommes pas partis
pareil on fera faire des retouches gens
n'auront pas de ça surtout à scouts
je serai franc avec vous nous ne pouvons
pas nous marquer du tour pourquoi et
bien pour commencer je ne suis pas une
fête l'ont pas d'importance je fume je
fume comme ça peuvent savez d'égal pour
passer du papier je vis depuis trois
hommes avec un joueur de saxophone
chaloupe à thann et lance je ne peux pas
encore d'enfant nous en adoptant vous ne
comprenez pas à ce coup je suis un homme
à personne n'est parfait
[Musique]
bonsoir de crem s'il vous plaît pardon
de créole vous êtes nouveau et origin 1
laissez moi vous dire qu'après les
femmes et les chiens le meilleur ami de
l'homme et le creal crème vous m'écoutez
et rues vides
une gorgée de rhum blanc ajouter un peu
de citron un tir de vermouth fera une
eau glacée et une petite dose de
grenadine agité longuement ajouter de la
glace pilée j'insiste agitée et servait
dans une coupe et mettez une olive de me
parler
nous non c'est moi qui ai dit 2-2 vous
étiez parfait jusqu aux olives
oui deux olives de cette manière vous
les verrez s'entrechoquer mollement
l'une contre l'autre
je vous avouerai que le spectacle de
deux olives s'entrechoquant meulemans
l'une contre l'autre est un plaisir dont
je me priverais une seule mais vous
n'allez tout de même passer par une
paire pourquoi pas c'est cruel
2 je vous parie que vous allez me
remerciez j'ai tout de même le droit de
boire ce que je veux une ne l'écoutait
pas deux mais vous buvez ce que vous
voulez mais duke et vous un peu d'eux
j'ai quand même des chances d'être au
courant
enfin le créole crème est une boisson de
chez nous bon alors vous devriez savoir
qu'elle vient d'un pays du sud créé par
un homme de goût il était donc de mon
pays une olive
ah bon ah j'avais pas ça si vous voulez
d'autres le sont à vous je pensais vous
rendre service tout simplement bien dans
ce cas pourquoi ne pas quitter le bar où
le restaurant ou mieux encore le pays
est écoutée vieux surtout ne m'appelez
pas vieux
on pourrait penser que c'est une marque
d'amitié vous voulez recevoir une baffe
non et vous or je pense que vous pourrez
prendre tous chez vous vous avez une
qualité certaine le courage oui alors à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur c'était de
choisir oui et bien à l'intérieur de or
il n'y a pas l'air conditionné camp nou
lors sinclair par ici ne vous inquiétez
pas voyons tous les dégâts vous seront
entièrement payée l'ordre sinclair vous
avez entendu ce que n'est encore jamais
massacré de l'ordre une autre qualité
le petit millier m'excuser j'ai glissé
rester là voulez vous que vous n'avez
rien mais laisse moi de regarder
asseyez-vous chéri gens n'est pas une
petite minute non j'ai pas besoin de
votre avis m'intéresse pas ça vous je
dégage le monsieur en dessous
[Musique]
buts je vais bien dégagée n'est ce pas
[Applaudissements]
eh bien nous voilà en effet faire ça va
c'est d'ailleurs elle qui est venue plus
tôt finalement pas très bien oui il ya
les voiles à aller au plaisir c'est
gentil vous avez dépanner mais bien là
c'est un problème c'est que si vous
voulez des gens moyens quoi ramener la
moyenne on a commencé ma place était
maintenant acceptable que nous on a été
choisi mais vraiment scientifiquement a
les moyens pendant jambes et en mes
moyens
on est tellement moyens qui voulait on
en est on avait vraiment moyen
jean-pierre dans les quartiers pour être
quartier tu sais bien comment nous
appelle table a les moyens qui passe
bien voilà ça c'est quand on fait le
match et que les moyens d'acheter des
choses qu'ils voulaient être moyen non
mais vous commencez pas possible suis
pas
samassa sa musique music musique music
musique
ville
bisous
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
c'est réglé ça va oui ça va bien un
problème
bon va simplement aller se faire une
petite beauté leur accord oui pour
weezer oui on y va tuer à tout de suite
et voici maintenant la séquence
d'actualité d'art d'imac agitation face
à quelques semaines des législatives
sur les images que vous allez voir les
fameuses éléphants du ps s'entraîne à
garder vertières il démarre pas
je crois est la viande
termine
m
autre chose
[Musique]
mon coeur
je ne pense pas
non je craindrais l'autre
[Musique]
saddam hussein at il réussi à
reconstruire sa centrale atomique
des images que vous allez voir que i par
les satellites espions américains ne
laisse aucun doute sur la reprise des
essais nucléaires
ce en attendant la revente d'adidas
bernard tapie tentent de prendre le
contrôle des chaussures andré mais ses
premières démarches restent sans succès
regarde et voici notre deuxième invité
fanny ardant
[Musique]
leur famille j'ai souvent entendu les
hommes dire de vous fanny ardant est une
femme qui plaît aux femmes pas aux
hommes pourquoi
fanny si je devais faire un portrait de
vous je dirai simplement insolite est
totalement insaisissables
y at il des époques de votre vie dont
vous refusez de par les fans il est
question q comment ça va fanny top 3
fautes
thierry question incongrue c'est de
l'audimat facile vous connaissez le
tarif vous connaissez la sanction 18
secondes de venise et s'amuser omni
nullement altérée par la variété des
styles
ainsi le gothique le plus médiéval
s'adosse avec bonheur au baroque le plus
délirant un gothique du sud avec des
ogives ensoleillé qui ont des cambrures
mauresque et voilà thirion vient
d'enregistrer une baisse catastrophique
je sais ce que vous allez me dire vous
allez me dire c'est denis mais ce n'est
pas venu c'est vos questions incongrues
qui nous font plonger alors maintenant
débrouillez vous thierry j'ai la
solution on voit si arielle dombasle
[Applaudissements]
fait un véritable tabac mécontents c'est
agréable
oui finalement les siffler on sait
jamais aux états unis ça veut dire c'est
très bien mais en france je ne sais pas
j'espère que les deux films à la fiche
desquels vous êtes auront le même succès
parce que c'était l'affiché de deux
films un film de romer qui s'appelle
comment l'arbre le maire et la
médiathèque et un fils de daniel schmid
s'appelle hors saison alors le film de
rumeurs c'est incroyable parce qu'à une
époque où on a vu les acteurs des
visiteurs faire comme ça toutes les
émissions de télévision david clavier
lemercier partout lui non pas du tout
rien du tout c'est à dire que ce film
est sorti dans le dense mais pas de
l'indifférence et le secret absolu ni le
secret n'a rien voulu dire les non non
non il a fait exprès il trouve qu'on est
quand même dans une époque où on parle
beaucoup des films et qu'on n'a pas
besoin que souvent et il le pense et je
crois qu'il a raison le public à une
sorte de sixième sens plus que le bouche
à oreille quelque chose presque de
l'ordre de la magie c'est quels sont les
films qu'il faut aller voir
et on a beau voir les pauvres acteurs
qui parle des films des heures dans les
émissions c'est pas ça qui fait que les
gens ils vont et donc il a misé
simplement sur la forte son film et il
est sorti aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
public je me dis mais comment est ce
possible alors que j'appelle rumeurs
quand même c'est sa survie dans une
seule salle en plus une seule salle
alors après il y en aura d'autres
peut-être même mais une seule salle pour
voir si ça plait je trouve que c'est
formidable
ce manque de stratégie celle à 100 mais
peut-être hume un peut-être alors un an
+ film est sorti on peut en parler oui
cela l'histoire
c'était son premier film politique et
alors il ya donc fabrice luchini pascal
greggory clémentine amouroux et nous
sommes tous des personnages de droite de
gauche des écolos et c'est à vue qui
n'est pas partisan c'est à dire qu'il
donne ses chances à chacun chacun ses
raisons et c'est très très drôle
comme toujours avec rohmer se reconnaît
dans les personnages rien autre film qui
s'appelle hors saison qui devait
schmitter là ça se passe dans un
magnifique palace désaffectée en suisse
c'est ça j'ai vu la photo j'ai eu envie
d'y aller tout de suite
ah oui mais il faut dire que daniel
d'abord est un signe as tu du grande
marginalité dans l'école de fassbinder
et c'est un film très singulier très à
lui qui vous émeut beaucoup c'est un
film qui vous fait immensément rêver
c'est un film où nous sommes des
personnages des fantômes et fantômes des
champions si vous voulez peuple et son
enfance alors il ya toute sorte
d'archétype qui se promène dans ce
palace désaffectée et on y voit andréa
ferréol et sami frey ingrid caven on
adore les champs de la soeur de fellini
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait maintenant alors
elle joue le rôle de la grand-mère qui
est un personnage comme ça très
légendaire qui a beaucoup compté pour
daniel schmitt et qui était la
propriétaire de cet hôtel
et puis il ya des magiciens il ya c'est
une autre époque on y rencontre sarah
bernhardt aussi qu'ils aient joué par
pas rêver on a vu chez almodovar est bon
c'est vraiment un film une sorte de
voyage dans le temps c'est dans les
années 40
qu'est-ce qui se passe oui c'est
parce que dans cette émission on a une
potiche quoi un peu comme sophie favier
chez chez dechavanne ou de ma nièce
boulard chez antoine de caunes
elle est engagée par les télévisions
japonaises mais c'est bon alors un gros
gros contrats à la fois jeune et fun tv
when you qui n'a pas embêtés parce que
l'audience
ah oui il vous faut une autre potiche un
autre prodige belge et vous acceptez
d'un petit peu mais je sais pas être un
petit peu serait possible juste un petit
juste pour faire remonter l'audience ça
c'est à dire à une quinzaine de secondes
comme ça voilà voilà mais est ce que
vous avez vraiment besoin d'une pause à
la télévision maintenant la télévision
maintenant il faut des potiches des
télés potiche ça fait monter l'audience
c'est connu c'est comme ça encore un
petit peu puis way we douter voilà vous
êtes sûr que que potiche et le mot
adéquat oui on n'a pas trouvé d'autre
mais il n'est pas il n'est pas très
inspirant pour tous vous attend et sa
commande et bien moi j'appelle ça une
sorte de présent stellaire ben disons ça
disons ça
je veux dire je crois que c'est une
lueur d'intelligence dans les yeux et
que ça m'étonnerait que vous fassiez
carrière comme petit sa tête plus tôt
chez pivot disons la limite sur les
potiches et pis si vous avez une grande
carrière ici à tous les cas merci tu es
sûr que tu sais pas ce que votre passage
fera pour le pour le film de romer et
pour celui de daniel schmitt
mais pour notre audience suis sûr c'est
là bien là merci ariane
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette heure-là unis ils nous menacent
qu'ils
sur le violence ouais on est mars à
katyn près de potiche jamais dicté une
potiche trois semaines le regarde dans
des missions tu m'as tu avais pas du
tout j'ai jamais dit ça de la vie hein
j'ai dit j'ai dit que ce fip aviez était
une petite île jamais été de ma planète
boularès que je m'appelle agnès je n'ai
jamais dit ça pour la bonne raison que
je sais que tu fais là la mode dans la
grande famille que dion des éditions que
tu fais tu connais fille s'habille pour
moins de 500 francs grâce à nous fait la
météo dans nulle part ailleurs la
science alors sa chance à comment aurais
je pu dire que t'étais une potiche je te
jure qu'il ait jamais dit ça sur la tête
de qui tu veux d'accord de leur vient
comme ça ça me fait plaisir même si tu
veux rester là par contre tu peux je
viens de faire plaisir parce que rester
un peu
c'est gentil ça va plus on applaudit la
nouvelle pige de l'aunis
[Applaudissements]
professeur je crois qu'à cette heure-là
il ya quand même un gros danger sur
l'audience non un gros gros gros gros
gros danger thierry ce danger a annoncé
le frigo aille parce qu'effectivement à
cette heure ci la plupart des gens ont
un petit creux
ils vont se diriger vers le frigo pour
aller chercher une bonne petite bière
bien moussu une bonne petite rondelle de
sauciflard et le petit livre si nous ne
voulons pas toucher le fond thierry il
faut absolument les dissuader de manger
ce qu'il faut pour les dégoûter mois la
petite ville de whiskas est est la
capitale mondiale du ver de terre ici
les annélides son manger à toutes les
sauces dans des milliers de familles les
ménagères ont inventé pour eux de
succulentes recettes rôti sauter en
friture empâté en ragoût
mais les vrais gourmets les préfère au
naturel tout frais sorti de la vase
[Musique]
enfin ces vers de terre sont utilisés
pour confectionner une boisson qui est
paraît-il très saine savoureuse même est
riche en vitamines et sels minéraux
c'est la boisson favorite des enfants
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
beau
il
[Musique]
formidable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
à
formidable cheese à bf3 y aura bel et
bien fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
max des docks et noël 2
communiqué
machado qui nous et nos atouts aussi au
monde juste et en qui tu es
machiste est guy novés nord
chacun dit ce procès
l'actrice s'est image répugnante n'ont
pas suffi les gens je le vois sont quand
même allés au frigo ils ont quitté leur
téléviseur l'audimat est au plus bas
c'est j'en ai marre de cette pression de
l'audience mais j'en ai marre bah oui
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que j'y fasse
c'est le jeu quand je pense qu'à une
époque où il y avait pas de dymat
souvent de regarder la même chose
saoulé et maintenant le rideau va se
lever sur un décor qui a été composé
pour cette première partie du récital de
la callas elle doit commencer avec l'air
de casta diva extrait de la norma de
bellini norma de bellini fut créée par
l'ama libre
c'est une invocation une invocation à la
lune le personnage qu'interprète la
callas dans la norme et celui de la
fille d'un druide
car alors massot passent au temps des
gaulois la fille d'un druide qui a été
l'amant d'un proconsul romain qui l'a
abandonné et elle invoque la ds à 5 les
gaulois l'aï pas tué son amant voici la
callas
[Musique]
non
si brefs délais
câble vous êtes gentils charlie
formidable formidable dit pas c'est pas
formidable thierry la courbe n'est pas
formidable du tout on est au plus bas
il faut qu est ce qui vient maintenant
j'ai plus rien là comment vous n'avez
plus rien alors là le chien il va y
passer mon petit chien il y passera
bah écoute et tirent ils voulaient mais
son chien je laime mais qu'est ce que
voulez que j'y peux rien changer plus
une cassette j'ai pris un document a
tenté une sortie je vais les chercher de
l'audimat d'or et ben voilà allez-y
thierry givet manu tu viens stéphane tu
viens
[Musique]
le coup
et
mais
[Musique]
m
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
recensant les jeunes
quel bonheur je suis mais qu'est ce que
tu fais là
thierry salaun minutes avant tout c'est
ce qui se passe qu'est 6,9
j'ai plus d'audience à ya mon émission
j'ai pu rien à diffuser j'ai pu rien à
[ __ ] dans cet espace est occupé
jean-marie déjà vu une paire de couilles
en or non ça peut peut-être l'on sait ça
peut relancer
je suis bien non je te promets rien mon
voyage avec nous que tu m eh ben je vais
t'aider
thierry on n'y croit on se bat c'est par
ici à leurs fins qu'est-ce que c'était
bien je me suis levé le morceau choisi
bon franchisé branché qui est là voilà
tu veux me fila l'ambiance à la gauche
je vais enfiler un petit peut jamais
garder d'emballage extra
mais aussi appel cortisone
j'ai pas le fait
d'ailleurs moi je me sente maillage la
recommande une seule écoute je bois un
petit coup de bordeaux on avait vu avant
la remontée un peu a dit oh là là là là
l'homme avait fait monter l'audience
vas-y matin vas-y ça monte ça monte
éventuellement peut-être sur le web se
taisent
vas-y ça monte ça monte ça monte bien
éventuellement sa balle a peut-être sur
un an grâce aux sciences
je suis content mais a sauvé le chiffre
grâce à andres avait le chien merci les
amis
bon alors on attend un coup je vais leur
mettre un petit goût non plus d'hier
s'est sauvé pour une relation mais
l'audience merci un puissant vent météo
bonne appartement pouvait plus d'un seul
coup il est pur et la diffuser non là
c'est tombé études
l'ambiance était promis l'appui de
documents à diffuser j'ai un bon niveau
j'y vais j'ai pris deux cadreurs
stéphanie manu jeu vers la pia et je
veux couper le bigard à la sortie de sel
en plus ça me fait vraiment plaisir que
tu as et moi vraiment dante dans la
merde que l'orgue de toi quand tu
vraiment il n'ya plus d'autre solution
je pensais moi c'est le bon arbre à coup
on voit que valenciennes est la tienne
[Musique]
on vous dire aux gens qu'on aime qu'on
est dans ta loge donc à l'olympia oui je
sais le sais ça fait combien de jours
cinq jours s'annoncent aussi de près les
cinq jours et puis c'est à dire c'est
c'est tout bon c'est une banalité de
dire le lundi aux mondiaux à la pilote
voir si j'aime bien les deux
je vais dire que moi j'ai du coup il se
dira que bachelot c'est génial comme les
autres
on a l'impression que j'ai eue à la la
première c'est que par rapport à
également quand je t'ai vue au palais
des glaces
c'est que les gens tu les tiens vraiment
bien c'est à dire que là on a
l'impression que tu fais ce que tu veux
avec eux tu joues un peu commun comme un
chat qui joue avec la souris quoi tu les
jeux les arrêts tu leur prends tu les
radins tué relais ce que la pression ça
fait combien de gens c'est ça aille à
2000 et des boîtes qu à peu près pas ce
qu'est ce que ce que j'essaye de faire
ce que je suis arrivé par expérience à
faire pour me complimenter c'est que
j'arrive là non c'est que j'arrive à
jouer une grande salle maintenant comme
une petite salle si j'arrive à jouer au
coin du feu avec les gens comme comme au
point virgule 4g devrait s'y atteler à
l'entracte tu l'as vu les strictes à et
je suis recherché les gens au balcon
chez les gens et bars qui me vint canon
et les gens ils en reviennent paul quoi
ils comprennent l'un des grands
champions versa et puis j'y allais
chercher janvier lyon finit première
parce que on y va je signale qu'il
regarde que ça 10 mai à diana 2 où ils
ont après un autre qui ressemble c'est
un gag
et puis je reviens tranquillement soit
on s'aime on rattaque deuxième partie et
puis 16 c'est un bonheur que la vraie
pas droit l'intense non massera on dit
moi c'est un froid non je t'aime 6-1
non mais c'est vrai qu'elle est un peu
comme un bouffon
tout serait cortisone lâché 1 les
canaris avec ça tu crois pour être en
forme alors que dans dans le comique de
sel en ce moment comme ça tombe ça pour
ma hervé guibert les les trucs qui met
en forme
bah moi je trouve que c'est dégueulasse
moi je trouve que c'est pas bien je dis
qu'il faut pas marcher sur les clones
ouais je dis qu'il nous casse les
couilles tous autant qu'ils sont marche
pas sur les clowns bordel même si c'est
avec le pied gauche sa porte pas bonheur
j'ai bien sûr donc
critique il faut pas emmerder les gens
c'est le fou du roi avant j'en discutais
avec un ami commun à laurent baffie le
fou du roi vous pouvez lire d'étape
excusez pas couper la tête il avait le
droit et ben nous on joue gros ce
rôle-là du fou du roi nous les comics
les déconneur et on aider je veux dire
tournée des grands reporters de de lave
de de l'âme humaine
c'est des reporters de l'âme humaine
c'est qu'on va dans les coins les plus
vicieux par toucher les gens ou chez
veut que 10 aces aussi l'arrivée on est
encore plus quand les gens sains souvent
individuellement ça va souvent mieux
mais dire on va chercher nos là dedans
ce qu'il ya de bon ce qui est mauvais ce
qui est bizarre rigolo pineau on ramène
tout ça en fait rire avec ça et bah si
j'aimais effectivement nous cette
catégorie jeunes si on n'est pas libre
c'est un grand reporter il est un livre
tout d'un coup d'aller avec ses
camarades ont droit qu elle formellement
interdite pour ramener justement des
images au monde c'est pareil on va dans
des endroits c'est vrai les gens passent
la ligne jaune quelques fois les
artistes et trucs comme ça qu'on vienne
pas leur casser les couilles
alors je sais il blanche mais je dire
qu'on vient de nous alors si jamais on
dit ça à ce moment là il faut déjà mon
frère était déjà les gros trafiquants si
jamais on parle du bordel
il faut dire que les mecs bien élevé qui
sont polis et tous qui l'univers des
touffes c'est là aussi que ben le pognon
blanchir les narcodollars bon en revers
dans ces pays là où tout va bien quel
homme politique anti machin conduit en
jeannette le bon bout quand un mec en
campagne électorale on his l'étape 70
villes en quinze jours bien l'époque et
prennent des trous et que je dis que tu
dis que de toute façon certainement que
médicalement ils sont soutenez un peu là
soit justement comme cat et nick et de
la gorge
tu prends de la cortisone 'etat nul
parce que tu arrives tu es comme ça bon
bah ya ça et puis après frei quand même
aussi dire tout si un militaire il a
besoin de faire huit jours un truc doit
revenir conviennent pas casser les
couilles au comique va donner là pour
distraire les gens le maroc attend alors
des ambitions des monnaies les plus
fragiles
donc si si elle est des mecs au
contraire des arts dits qui sont les
plus fragiles qu'on a eu un problème
avec ça qu'on les laisse se démerder
l'excellent même là et puis que les
petits journaux de mer deviennent pas
vendre leur camelote avec ça ou alors il
faut tout remettre en ordre
et bien sûr voilà moi je sais bien qu'on
ouvre notre gueule et puis nous on est
là pour rigoler lors qu'on va se mettre
à se marrer que tu vois des papys et des
mamies qui disent on regarde la petite
roumaine jambes et regarde la petite
chinoise où il ya le petit machin cd
gamine qu'on a drogué à 10 ans alors les
empêcher de grandir
est-ce qu'on fait pas un entraînement
pour une compétition comme les jeux
olympiques avec une médaille à l'appui
en fait pas un entraînement de quatre
ans avec une gamine qui grandit de 15 cm
je suis désolé mais toutes les gamines
au monde entre 10 ans et 15 ans a grandi
de 15 cm on n'y peut rien c'est la
nature pour les blocs et puis toutes les
papys et mamies jusqu'à ce que c'est
génial le sport c'est super super le
sport ou une saison que tu es en
décrocher mais en les re laisse grandir
et bien 25 ans tu regardes les genoux il
m'a chalon l'arthrose de femme de 65 ans
et à 100 grabataire à 45
maintenant rien avant les ans ramène une
médaille alors toi les mails dans le
tour de france qui se piquent le machin
et tout que ce soit tous les
laboratoires ambulants qui court le 100
m en 7 secondes banon dis moi tu veux
que je déclare donc tu gagnes pas mal de
pognon
ouais tu vas y ça donne
je vais faire ni chez toi et ouais c'est
à sète a coûté cher ça veut dire que tu
gagnes beaucoup
non ça va vous coûter cher les gens ils
en moi je gagnais pas un rouge et or a
été très pauvre jeu maintenant je gagne
de l'argent je dis aux gens je suis
heureux comme un gosse je gagne plein de
pognon
qu'est ce qu'on va faire chier avec ça
toute façon mon contrôleur fiscal il le
sait
g j'ai une société g la mâche un doute
là je fais passer ma famille là dessus
parce que c'est beaucoup plus sérieux
c'est mon frère jean-pierre que ce
groupe d tout au centime près ça me
permet de continuer mois à faire le con
comme j'ai envie et puis qui serre les
boulons derrière
et puis bah en france ça c'est encore un
certain monsieur françois pas le droit
non du tout les gens là ah non la preuve
je sais pas si je te raconter une
anecdote n'a que j'ai dit chez toi l
époque donc j'ai dit d'ailleurs pour
laisser ça sans rival pas mal c'est
difficile ce n'est pas elle et que 300
milles alors que là il ya une 600 me et
6 en matinée les émissions similaires
soient tous les noms à sa tante ça ne
s'écrit d'épaulé non seulement pas
seulement les gens ils m'en veulent pas
ils sont comment veux tu sais c'est
vraiment un tableau de l'argent en
france incroyable je raconterai l'unique
de tia coup sûr là dessus sur le pognon
justement est donc j'arrive au ski avoir
10 avril cinq cent mille balles par mois
la société est en tout cas et alors je
vois un mec dans un chalet à la montagne
doit jean marie lebée que tu nous as dit
que de gagner 5 octobre le bal par mois
les tu peux payer un canon à ginon bas
50 mais ça sent mais mieux je cherche
pas d'excusés mais un canon un ami sont
s'en fout guy lacombe juste bons à
l'échangé ont compris je gagnais pas mal
de pognon qui pillent pognon que j'y
gagne moi je peux regarder tout le monde
dans les yeux
c'est à dire que sans merlan que tu
gagnes
plein de pognon but fait des choses pas
très sadique là bas moi je gagne pas les
gens viennent me voir ils payent de
nombreux américains et puis c'est ce
pognon là que je gagne j'ai grandi ici
rigole pages à l'ubs à une pole pagne en
6è 500 personnes au lieu de 2000 banca
trois mois et puis c'est tout mais c'est
dire je vais en péril personnes moi je
vis ma part les amis éviter que les
morgues érigées est un peu vrai j'ai dit
ok c'est moi le partage du travail j'y
vois jouer je crois qu'on a plus de
cassettes la tra merde c'était
intéressant cependant encore bon je suis
limite bondi au revoir leurs bordures
voir les mecs
[ __ ] ça lui y arriver j'ai une paire
de couilles honneur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de la
latitude
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu